Nóng ngày 18 năm, thông tin từ bình Việt đã khoa 2 đông,
đơn vị vừa tiếp nhận và suy chiến thình công 1 năm bình nhân,
3 mi ba tuổi, đi một con zét sống chui và tài khi đang ngủ.
Chứ đó, tình rất sọ một đêm buổi tại công chương,
bánh nhân thấy đau tay phải sử dụt, cảm giác lùu của không hay.
Ní rằng chỉ là dễ tai khoa cuu trung nhỏ,
bánh nhân đã dùng tâm bông ngoại tai để làm sạch.
Sau khi ngoái, cơn đau trở nên sử dụi hơn,
kênh theo cảm giác nhất bút, bánh nhân để khoa tai mối họ,
bánh Việt đã khoa 2 đông bị kìm tra.
Qua kiểm tra các bác sĩ phát hiện một con zét sải khoảng 5 cm còn sống
đang bỏ trong ông tài ngoại của bánh nhân.
Con bình đã quay tổng thương nghiệm mà giấn đến trình dịch và kích ứng mạnh.
Khi trực đã quay tê tại chốt, dùng dụng cụ truy xuống các con zét sàng ngoại.
Sau thủ thuật, bánh nhân được theo dõi và xuất vị trì vài dựa sợ đó.
Mày mạnh mạnh nghĩ không bị tổng thương, tính nước hoàn toàn bình thường.
Bác sĩ nguyễn an giúng, chử khoa tai mối họ, cho biết,
các tên hạnh sò dị vật đường tay, mối họ không nghĩ em gặp trong thực hành lực sàng.
Dù thường sẽ giá ở trẻ em gió các vật nhỏ như hạt đầu,
cúp áo người lớn cũng có thể gặp phải tỉ ngúng tương tự.
Đặc biệt là khi vụ ở mối trường ẩm thấp khoảng ngoại trời mà không có mạnh trẻ,
tạo được kiện cho các loại cuo chúng như gián, mối, hai thậm sĩ là dễ truy vào.
Các chuyên giá ít tế cạnh báo, khi có dị vật trong tay,
tự đối không được tự sự lý tại nhà bằng tâm bông, vật nhỏnh họng nhỏ dầu.
Những hình động này chỉ khiến dị vật đi số hơn,
người tổn thường ổng thay, tổng mạng ý và những chúng nào.
Hì có có giấu hiệu bất tự như đau tay,
ủ tay, nhà kêm hai cảm giác có vật là sau khi vụ dệ,
cân đến ngày cơ sở y tế truy qua để được các thiệp ký tối và đúng cách.